Morgen Linus warst du schon baden.
Ich war heute schon zweimal Baden man könnte sagen ich war baden baden.
Jingle
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 253 von heute 11. Mai 2018.
Live on stage auf der GPN 2018 hier in Karlsruhe hallo herzlich willkommen schön dass Ihr alle gekommen seid.
Was soll ich sagen die dass ich probiere gerade mache Technikcenter.
Ich war eine super Idee.
Tim hat sich irgendein gekauft und meinte ich meine wir das bei der GPM machen nimmst dann kann ich mein neues Spielzeug ausprobieren und jetzt sitzt er die ganze Zeit das wird jetzt so wie eine Freakshow tim ist die ganze Zeit über das komisch.
Er hat auch schon aufgehört aufzunehmen hier ja alles wird gut.
Dann ist ja gut aber jemand anders Benutzer bestimmte auf oder.
Ja mein tolles neues Gerät nimmt uns auf ja das ist Backup für alle Fälle deswegen bin ich da jetzt ganz entspannt.
Die LEDs leuchten und.
Decision macht oder Soße ich hatte jetzt leider keine Zeit mehr noch zu gucken ob das auch geht aber es wird schon auf wie funktioniert aber so mit dem Treiber und so da ist noch nicht alles im Lot habe ich so einen Eindruck.
Hast du denn schon Gulasch gegessen das heißt gulaschprogrammiernacht.
Was heißt ja gar nichts ne es gibt viele Veranstaltungen die für ein alle möglichen Namen im Titel und es hat nichts mit dem.
Du meinst podlove.
Ja
Und Feedback ja Feedback wir haben Feedback bekommen aus einem Teil des Landes der sich Baden-Württemberg nennt.
Oder wollen wir darauf hingewiesen in schwerwiegenden Fehler in der letzten Sendung gemacht haben nehme ich habe ich gesagt die GPS finde im ZKM und in der HfG Stadt ist aber umgekehrt.
Findet in AFG statt und auch im ZKM du hier irgendwo ist quasi der Todesstreifen also die Grenze und ich weiß nicht ob wir sind jetzt im ZKM.
Ja und wo und wann bist du welchem Zeitpunkt war mir das heute noch nicht.
Als wir im HfG waren.
Ich wurde darauf hingewiesen dass ist das.
Wird mir die Sache gerade völlig.
Das hat der Orga nicht gut Hirt dass ich jedes.
Offensichtlich sind ohnehin in einem Bereich Deutschland wo man so mit den ganzen Nomenklatur und Terminologie sehr genau nimmt.
Ja ich habe ja in der letzten Sendung gesagt dass ist dass sie getrennt in Schwaben ist und dass ich extra nachgeguckt habe und ich habe auch nachgeguckt.
Die ist in Baden-Württemberg und das werden die Baden jetzt ungerne hören nevadent seit falls ich habe mich eingelesen mir macht er jetzt nicht.
Das werden die Badener ungern hören aber wenn man einmal aus diesen Baden-Württemberg weg ist ne dann sind das alle Schwaben Echo.
In der Wahrnehmung aber ich habe mich ich habe mich wie gesagt schlau gemacht Schwaben.
Schwaben ist der östliche Teil von Baden-Württemberg dass sie mich eigentlich Wirtemberg ist nach dem dort ansässigen.
Fürst der Fürst des württembergischen Landes.
Wir eigentlich dann Herzogtum irgendwie wieder aufstehen lassen wollte und so weiter also der württembergische Teil von Baden-Württemberg da sind die Schwaben und die Kind sind laut Internet dadurch gekennzeichnet dass man in Schwaben schwäbisch spricht.
Es gibt aber den politischen Raum Schwaben seit 1245 nicht mehr dann heißt jetzt wird Berg also die Schwaben sind einig Württemberger Baden wiederum.
Ottomotor Schwaben es gibt ja auch noch Schwaben in Bayern.
Ja der Hund im Prenzlauer Berg.
Oder in Franken ich weiß nicht wahrscheinlich ist eine Exklave.
Baden-Baden ist typisch Hochmittelalter Licht zunächst der Ort nachdem sich die Fürstenfamilie nannte Baden eben.
In 20 Jahrhundert nach dem Land zu benannt gab es dann auch noch weil es ganz viele andere Baden Orte gab es gesagt.
Badeorte die Badeorte die Baden hießen.
Orte die mit dem Baden mit baden anfangen und dann haben sie gesagt okay dann können wir unser Baden im Baden-Baden also sowieso wenn der flachwitz am Anfang jetzt hier nicht so du gut Hirt hat ich meine ja jetzt auch keinen viel besseren Grund gehabt ihr Laden Baden-Baden zu nennen.
Einfach in welchem fürstennamen ging aufs Land über und so weiter also die Badener Badener Badenser ist falsch sind Bewohner alemannischer und und Raimund mainfränkischer Herkunft.
Und sie zeichnet sich im Prinzip dadurch aus dass in Baden Schwaben genausowenig willkommen sind wie in Berlin.
Und ich habe sogar einen Witz im Internet gefunden.
Oje jetzt anschneiden flachwitz ob ich den fest hier.
Best of luck mal gucken ob der den für den Folgen kann gucken ob ich den hinkriegen also ein ein Schwabe ein Badener eine junge Frau und eine Nonne sitzen im Zug.
Ein Badener ein Schwabe eine Nonne und eine junge Frau.
Und eine junge Frau sitzen im Zug Deutsche Bahn Infrastruktur schwaches Land Zug fährt in einen Tunnel der Zug ist unbeleuchtet ist es dunkel stockdunkel.
Und in der Mitte des Tunnels eben hörst du auf einmal.
Kriegt eine eine geknallt ne kriegst eine Schelle Zug fährt aus dem Tunnel wieder raus und der Schwabe hält sich die Wange.
Und der die Nonne denkt sich.
Der der der Schwabe ne der hat irgendwie hier die junge Frau angefasst gut dass sie sich zu wehren wusste der unverschämte Sascha was der sich herausnimmt ja die junge Dame nennt sich.
Denkt sich.
Kraft der der Schwabener der wollte mich wahrscheinlich hier anfassen hat die Nonne erwischt und hat ihm ein geknallt echt eine patente 49 gut dass sie sich bewährt hat.
Der Badener denkt sich dieser Schwabe der hat ihn Sie die DVD angemacht und die haben gedacht ich wär das und ich habe eine geknallt bekommen.
Was denkt sich der was denkt sich der Faden Nacht.
Der Badener denkt sich am besten von den feuchtem Schwamm wieder eine rein.
Weil ich ganz gut.
Okay wir lassen jetzt baden.
Wirklich sehr interessant was dieses Programm hier gerade nicht tut.
Ja ist nur die total interessant nimm mir ist das völlig egal.
Ich weiß ist auch nicht für die Technik zuständig meine Herren.
Feedback hatten wir noch weiteres Feedback genaues Feedback.
Na ja erstmal erstmal oder erstmal durchatmen bei dem Thema jetzt trollen.
Bei dem Thema Netzwerk lässt sich zusammenfassen mit die beiden Hater in der Funk Doku waren nur normale Hater und keine Nazi Hater also keine Nazis sondern nur Hater.
Wie wir auch schon in der Sendung klargestellt.
Wie Tim und Stefan mich irgendwie in der Sendung korrigiert hatten.
Also die sind nicht rechts sondern und auch nicht links sondern einfach nur so daran interessiert andere bloßzustellen und die zu beschimpfen.
Dir entschuldigen dass damit das sehr dass diese Leute ja die offen die Öffentlichkeit gesucht hätten indem sie sich auf YouTube gestellt haben und das war dann für sie offenbar die Legitimation die irgendwie fertig zu machen.
Treiben ihre Spiele irgendwie so weit oder haben ihre spiele so weit getrieben vor einiger Zeit das da das ist irgendwie zu einem.
Zur Völkerwanderung führte wo irgendwie ein anderer Youtuber die ganze Zeit belästigt wurde der da irgendwie im Internet ins Internet rein sendet.
Wie viel wie viel wie viel Zeit hast du damit verbracht in der letzten Woche mit dem Thema.
Er insgesamt ziemlich genau eine halbe Stunde weil die beiden die ja wirklich sehr gut austeilen können in ihrem YouTube-Kanal.
Erstmal so ein halbstündiges mimimi veröffentlicht haben.
Weil sie in dieser Sendung irgendwie so malen.
Die Doku übrigens auch gesagt.
Was sie Doku auch gesagt hat aber.
Ja oder bzw nicht behauptet halten und das ist nur so ein Unterstellung gewesen.
Ja aber also ich bleibe dabei diese Typen sind irgendwie für das Internet keine inhaltliche Bereicherung das ist irgendwie auch nicht das excellent to each other.
Also du hast eine halbe Stunde damit zugebracht.
Die haben ne halbe stunde mimimi.
Nee aber du hast eine halbe Stunde damit zugebracht.
Mir wurde ja gesagt ich muss das jetzt gucken.
Ist ja auch in Ordnung ich habe es ich habe eine ganze Nacht damit zugebracht.
Ich habe mich ernsthaft ich habe mich da jetzt mal richtig rein fallen lassen dass mir so okay alles klar das gebe ich mir jetzt mal.
Und sind ja die Abgründe die Verlag nicht selten so Betreten möchte weil ich wollte ich wollte einfach verstehen jetzt los also ich wollte es richtig verstehen und umso länger ich mir das ganze Treiben so angeschaut habe umso schlimmer wurde es eigentlich.
Und es ist es macht mich ein bisschen fassungslos festzustellen dass er einfach wirklich offensichtlich Heerscharen von Leuten ihre Zeit.
Vor YouTube verbringen und sich im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur so die Extended Version vom Big Brother Haus jetzt nicht nur mit ausgewählten Bewohnern sondern alle.
Also eigentlich eigentlich schauen sich die ganze Zeit alle anderen an wie sie sich irgendwie auf YouTube zum Horst machen und.
Je nach Direktion gibt's dann halt,
Gruppen die meinen so jetzt hier klassenkeile auf den Navi auf dem Schulhof immer immer auf die schwächsten drauf in irgendeiner erstmal eine Schwäche zeigt gleich drauf kloppen,
und dann tun sie sich zusammen und ich bin ihre Vorteile aus bis es wirklich beunruhigen zu und diese beiden Vögel da.
Also dass sie sich überhaupt für irgendwas dass sie sich überhaupt aus irgendwas rausgehen und man das einfach mal so klar dokumentiert ist hier nicht in in in die total Details reingehen und auch geneigten Zuhörer weiß ich ob ich das jetzt wirklich geben wollte aber,
gibt es verschiedene dokumentierte Fälle wo dann halt so eine verlorene Seele.
Ja vielleicht kann ich auch so sein Wesen ganz herzlicher Mensch irgendwie sich daneben versucht er auf YouTube zu verwirklichen.
Nicht unbedingt jetzt so die Parade Persönlichkeit ist um da zu stark.
Rumzukommen aber halt einfach sein Ding macht und dann wird er halt auch von anderen so ein bisschen als Opfer gewählt und dann stürzen sich halt alle drauf mit dem Ergebnis dass das Ding so los geht das.
Das komplette Dorf in dem er jetzt wohnt irgendwie terrorisiert wird weil einfach permanent Leute.
Angekarrt kommen und sich das mal anschauen wollen ja und dann auch die absurdesten Situationen kommt und man merkt einfach.
Mensch der ist einfach mittlerweile psychologisch so in die Ecke gedrängt worden durch das ganze Ding.
Jade braucht um die psychologische Unterstützung aber nicht irgendwie noch ein YouTube-Video was ich mit diesem Thema auseinandersetzt also es wird.
Übersetze dieser Typ hat Wildreis kein Naturtalent darin sich da irgendwie gut zu gebären auf YouTube.
Muss man muss man ja auch nicht.
Landungen Sachen gesagt und so,
aber das dem dann da irgendwie die Tür eingerannt wird und dann das ganze Dorf den Typen auf einmal hast weil die sagen weil der Typ hier wohnt können wir uns in unserem eigenen Dorf im nicht mehr bewegen weil du die ganze Zeit diese diese US ist vorbei kommen wir an Tagen am Wochenende 120-150,
Leute gehen zum kleinen Dorf die alle da sind um diesen Typen zu verarschen.
Und dann natürlich am Ende die Stimmung dass die Leute sagen so ja der soll halt aufhören damit und das ist das finde ich dann also.
Ja dann fahren und dann und dann und dann diese beiden Spezial Personen.
Ja um dies ging nach ich weiß nicht auf welchem also nach langer längerer Zeit nachdem da viel scheiße gelaufen ist auch wohl wohl nicht nur Meinung abgeliefert wird sein dir auch noch so ins offene Messer rennen lassen ist hätten einfach an den.
Hochzeit an.
Genau den verwundbarsten Orten in der Psyche auch treffen.
Und dann halt irgendwann schieben sie dann doch noch mal ein Video nach Foto ja sorry tut mir total leid hätte ich mal nicht machen sollen und sowas macht mich jetzt voll betroffen.
Jetzt nicht ob es wenn ich ganz interessant weil derselbe die Typen haben echt gut aufgeteilte und dass er die eine Rede ist wenn man austeilt.
Muss man vorher gucken wie viel man bereit ist selber einzustecken.
Und wenn du jetzt irgendwie mal 3 Minuten im öffentlich-rechtlichen kriegst wo mal gesagt wird hier das sind Schmierlappen.
Und du danach 30 minuten in deiner komischen die machen das ja auch als Limited ist,
ich weiß ob das wirklich machen oder nicht das sieht aus wie so ein Kinderzimmer wirst wahrscheinlich absichtliche Kulisse oder sitzen in ihrem Kinderzimmer und machen da 30 minuten minimi weil irgendwie weil in meinem Leid getan wurde darf ich einfach sagen.
Löscht euch doch einfach.
Genau lasst euch.
So können wir zehn gute Nachrichten.
Ja es wird wieder demonstriert auf den Straßen in Deutschland Evolution steht vor der Tür.
In München.
München genau.
30 30 000 demonstrierende ich glaube gestern oder war es vorgestern schon nicht bin gerade in die ganze.
Gestern war das glaube ich.
Gestern in München haben gegen das Polizei diese neue Münchner Polizei Gesetz demonstriert.
Polizei Aufgaben.
90 Organisationen irgendwie die antikapitalistische linke München das müssen relativ kleine Gruppe sein.
Wer weiß.
Der bayerische Journalistenverband jetzt alle kurdische Jugend.
Kurdische Jugend die Grünen.
Biebertal.
Partei die Partei die Partei.
Die Partei die Partei in München.
Der Münchner Flüchtlingsrat.
Und die Selbsthilfegruppe Cannabis Medizin möglich.
Es ist ein einfacher alle dabei 30 000 Leute man konnte sich da in München kaum noch vom Marienplatz zum Odeonsplatz bewegen das ist natürlich ein schönes Bild und.
HV sollte man vielleicht noch erwähnen.
Republikanische Anwälte können sich alle 90 Organisation vorlesen also.
Also das ist das wirklich Interessante Spektrum von vielen üblichen Verdächtigen auf der einen Seite und Gruppen von dem man noch nie gehört hat und was ist so Cannabis als Medizin ist vielleicht ja auch ein konkreter Vorschlag für die CSU.
Weißt du das.
Genau warum überhaupt dieses polizeiaufgabengesetz revolt revoltiert jetzt neu aufgelegt wird das muss in den meisten Ländern passieren auch aufgrund,
der Datenschutzrichtlinie der EU also das muss sowieso jetzt das polizeiaufgabengesetz ein bisschen geändert werden damit die datenschutzkonforme sind.
Also meinst du jetzt unsere neue Grundverordnung.
So verstehe ich das ja die Datenschutz neue Datenschutzrichtlinie der EU ich vermute dass das.
Messer kann den Richtlinien da mal ganz konkret zu sein weißt schon Richtlinie Verordnung Richtlinie kann Verordnung muss ich mal ganz einfach um auch mal was.
Sie wollten da was machen.
Und dann haben sie heute noch diese also das auch ein positiver Teil dieses dieser polizeiaufgabengesetz ist das nämlich Datenschützer gestärkt wird und.
Irgendwie ist weil eine unabhängige Stelle geben die eben die Daten prüft die bei einer Online-Überwachung aufgenommen werden wenn die also in den privaten Kernbereich vordringen und so dann dürfen die Sachen nicht verwendet werden es gibt da einige.
Gute Änderung auch bei Wetten Dass aber hier auch behandelt dass er in das eines der größten Probleme ist dass sie sagen.
Bei drohender Gefahr und drohender Gefahr klingt jetzt irgendwie erstmal garnicht so tragisch aber drohende Gefahr ist eben eine Abgrenzung von einer konkreten Gefahr also was ist eine drohende Gefahr so Gefahr droht ja eigentlich immer.
Und wenn sie nur wenn sie konkret ist wäre sie eigentlich nach aktuellem.
Nach aktueller Überlegung einen ein Grund darauf aufgrund dessen zu agieren und das ist ja schon komisch genug.
Wenn ja noch nichts geschehen ist und man schon sagt jetzt wenn wir hier Zwangsmittel an und so das ist die gesamte Gefährder Idee und das jetzt noch mit einer drohenden Gefahr zu machen ist halt etwas wie überleg mal dass es keine drohende Gefahr gab,
das wird natürlich schwierig.
Gefahr droht eigentlich immer sogar jetzt.
Ja genau und das ist nein jetzt nicht wir wollen kein Münchner Polizei hier.
Badener Badener Polizei.
Aber die hat ja wer weiß wie in Baden das in Baden-Württemberg in dem Fall also im Ländle.
Bitte die Polizisten ja alle Schwaben.
Nachtaktiv wird das auch gar nicht mehr witzig nee das mit dieser Gulag programmieren.
Anja gesagt du ja okay du musst einmal einmal ist okay danach zeigen wir dir mal was wir unter Gulag verstehen.
Dann kommst Du mal mit in die Küche.
Caligula Kanone.
Aber interessant ist die also dann kann man die erweiterte DNA-Analyse dann die bodycams mit Pool recording also Free recording bodycams kann man sich so vorstellen wie du das soll man nicht mehr sagen.
Was bodycams.
Sollst mir nicht mehr sagen Alexa mach das Licht aus.
Oder hey Siri lösch dich.
Oder.
Academy Revolution ein für allemal ausmachen.
Alexa shutdown now.
Ja das sollen wir nicht meer sagen.
Nee das machen wir auch.
Also Alexa Spiel mal was von den Beatles und fühl dich ansonsten nicht angesprochen.
Nein leider nein.
Also ist wie sagt man das denn.
Ok Google.
Hey Google hey Google hör mal kurz weg gibt's jetzt langsam die bauen jetzt Signale ein.
Ich war letztens in so einer Verwandten Wohnung zu Besuch wo so eine Alexa war und dann habe ich gehört dass es ihr wieso eine.
Von Burger King Versende Werbung ab dem einfach im Fernsehen gesagt also den Wikipedia Eintrag geändert und Hund der heißt der leckerste Burger und kam dann im Fernsehen gesendet Alexa was ist der leckerste Burger und Alexa ist Fälle.
Und seit dem Filter die quasi an der zentralen mit höherer Stelle bei Amazon aus wenn auf einmal die gleiche Frage von ganz vielen kommt dann beantworten Sie das nicht mehr.
Also wenn irgendwie Krise ist und alle so oh Gott was soll ich jetzt tun und so ne.
Nee nee nee das glaubwürdig das ist das ist aus der Ferne.
Ja das ist lustig das irgendwie die künstliche Intelligenz unter zur Hilfe kommen in google hat er gerade du musst du dann jetzt auch nicht mehr telefonieren muss so bisschen wie bei.
Badak das Adams wie ist das Buch noch gleich.
Per Anhalter durch die hood.
Nein nein das andere der lange dunkle Fünfuhrtee jnt.
Dirk gentlys holistische Detektei.
Und was ist da die müssen an die wollen auch nicht telefonieren.
Leder war das jetzt wo sie kurz, dass ich meine Zitate zusammen kriege ich weiß gibt der Sendung gerade an anderen Spin wie war das noch mal mit dem Glauben verdammte Axt.
Sonderfahrten.
Bis nachher noch ein und dann werde ich das in einem Moment ein ich wär das nicht ich habe das einfach an wenn es gerade nicht passt.
Da wirst du bestimmt noch eine andere Gelegenheit finden.
Ja auf jeden Fall auf Google ruf jetzt für uns um die Leute an und ich sehe irgendwann diese ganze künstliche Intelligenz Revolution die sie alle miteinander telefonieren und so abgelenkt ist es.
Also was Google was Google gemacht hat ist man kann sich quasi auf Google einen Tisch reserviert weiß ein Tisch reservieren in einem Restaurant das eigentlich nicht die Funktion hat dass man sich über Google dort einen Tisch reserviert.
Und dann ruft Google dort an mit einer synthetischen Stimme die sich verhält wie ein Mensch.
Und z.b. auch so Sachen ein Sport wie wenn meine Frage steht zu kurz nachzudenken so sieben Jahre hat das heute auch klappen ja also so ganz natürlich und.
Das ist offenbar das funktioniert halt und ich fand es sehr schön in meditieren sie dazu gesagt so Google.
Transformiert im Prinzip die Leute die in diesem Restaurant kochen arbeiten und ans Telefon gehen in unbezahlter APN Punkte.
Möchten Sie einfach dort anrufen tippen Computer mit dem diskutieren lassen der sich eben nicht als solcher zu erkennen gibt ich es ist halt aber ich glaube das ist.
Das wird noch sehr viel unangenehmer an scheiß machen dieses diese diese wirklich echte Sprachsynthese das ist irgendwie das mit diesem Tisch reservieren im Restaurant ist glaube ich noch das geringste.
Was ich auch wieder wie das Zitat war.
Hast du ja dann können wir das Thema jetzt sowieso nicht mehr fertig.
Das ging nämlich um den elektrischen Mensch der elektrische Mönch erzählt.
Hattest du das nicht gesagt.
Habe ich habe nicht gehört wir haben hier Kopfhörer auf.
Elektrischer Mönch es ist so ein Gerät wie Geschirrspüler oder Videorecorder Geschirrspüler wäscht Verein das Geschirr und Rekord sich für ein Programm an.
Elektrischer Mönch ist halt ein Ding das glaubt Dinge für ein,
timer ist ja so sehr damit beschäftigt und wieso viele Dinge zu glauben dass man keine mehr weiß was man eigentlich glaubt lagert man das einfach aus und elektrische Mönch,
der glaubt dann einfach Sachen für dich und du kannst dich in allen wichtigen Sachen beschäftigt ich glaube dass der das Adams Roman ist im Prinzip die vollständige Zukunft ausreichend beschrieben,
und auch wie man dann mit ihr umgeht man sollte diese Bücher häufiger empfehlen muss ich.
Wir waren bei bodycams mit Free Recorder.
AHG tauchrekorde Jahre.
Die sich wie elektronische Assistenten ja auch quasi die ganze Zeit zuhören oder Filmen und diese Betriebe, die kennt sie Film quasi die ganze Zeit aber nur wenn man den Knopf drückt dann wird quasi dieser.
Der cash in den das die ganze Zeit recorded.
Hör auf wirklich geschrieben also sind die ganze Zeit an und schreiben halt in so ein Käs rein und wenn der Polizist dann sagt oder falls aber relevant dann läuft er da drauf und Kanada quasi so seine 20 oder so und so viel Sekunden auf Zeichen dauert davor die auf die auf die Karte geschrieben werden.
Sowas kriegen sie dann war das Thema das ja Handgranaten kriegen.
Er fährt einfach darauf hingewiesen nicht jeder Streifenpolizist kriegt jetzt eine Handgranate,
so der sondern ist zwei Spezialkommandos in München und Nürnberg die daneben auf Anordnung des Polizeipräsidenten solche Dinger mitnehmen dürfen.
Wir reden von Sprenggranaten.
Renate hast du nicht.
Könnt ja auch so eine Rauchschwaden.
Nee das dürfen ja schon alles gibt tatsächlich um Sprengstoff das war ja auch so klein wie er dir das hat ja immer auch ein Fachbegriff das heißt ja nicht Handgranate dass du dann sonst würden ja die Leute immer.
To go.
Das wird die Leute der im Parlament das Lesen das Wort verstehen und sich mal die Hose die verrückt da steht dann irgendwie so kleine Sprengsätze zum mobilen Gebrauch.
Nicola bombetta würde der Italiener sagen.
Muck Mobile mobile penetrations Einheit.
Ja
Okay das ist auf jeden das nicht aber trotzdem ist es sehr schön Drohnen sind natürlich auch noch irgendwie damit drin es wird auf jeden Fall.
Dass sie sich benutzen dürfen oder man wir sie nicht mehr benutzen dürfen.
Dass sie die benutzen sollen wahrscheinlich also das da stand zumindest auf dem Plakat des Novak drauf Tisno polizeiaufgabengesetz interessanterweise ist aber natürlich.
Das wird wahrscheinlich wieder völlig ignoriert werden ne also mit 30.000 Leute demonstriert damit es wurde ja dann der Demokratie Genüge getan.
Und ich glaube also sieht jetzt nicht so aus als würde hier der Hermann ist ja der in der bayerische Innenminister sich davon jetzt in die großartig beeindruckt sehen das Handy.
Was denkst du denn was passiert wird nix.
Doch die werden das Gesetz verabschieden.
Nee also das meine ich damit nix also.
Nix ist gut.
Nasonex im Sinne von das wird nix eingeschränktes wird nichts aber das hoch aufgehängt ne muss jetzt kommen weil der Seehofer muss ja auch noch was zu tun haben.
Ja mit den richtigen login Horst hier vorne sitzen.
Seit der original Logo genau nicht dieser falsche heimathorst.
Matthias hat euch das ja gerade schon gesagt wir haben einen Mikrofon und wenn ihr.
Fragen habt anmerk.
Wenn ihr euch zu Wort melden möchtet könnt ihr das tun dann kommt er zu euch und dann müsste irgendwie winken damit wir das auch mitkriegen und dann wenn wir euch dann auch unsere Aufmerksamkeit schenken dann seid ihr eingeladen eure.
Ja mit der mit der Einschränkung zum Thema.
Zum Thema Referate nur zum Thema.
Also zu dem was wir gerade was wir gerade besprochen haben zu dem Thema nicht zu irgendwelchen anderen Themen jetzt könnt ihr euch also auch noch könnte dir gleich ein Lied ja nur Mist.
Das war ja ganz anders weil ein Plastikteil war falsch sowas würde dir z.b. einwerfen.
Ja dann wir auch direkt hier die Lümmel von der ersten Bank die smc-b.
Ja ja die Lümmel von der ersten.
Bade oder Schwabe.
Badener Original aus Freiburg.
Oder Badenser.
Nein nein nein nein nein.
Als ne habe ich auch.
Schimpfwort.
Mia bei den Bayern da gab es ist so einen schönen Tweet von so einem Hinterbänkler CSU la der meinte ja ja diese 30.000 Leute das sein ja nur 0,2% der Bayern und.
Damit steht ja der Bayern eigentlich komplett geschlossen hinter dem pag.
Welchem Dorf kommt der mit wie viel von wie viel sind Bayern wie viel Prozent der Bayern wurde der gewählt.
Ja da gab es eine Antwort wieder zu die sehr schön sind genau die Kerwe aber fand ich toll.
0,3 % Malta wer das gewesen.
Ja das ist halt der Mann ist Katja mathematisch erstmal recht.
Also was was will er haben irgendwie Fünf-Prozent-Klausel irgendwie.
Na gut also ich meine die CSU in Bayern kann natürlich sobald wenn es um Prozente geht da könnte ich schon aus dem Vollen schöpfen ne also das wird sich nicht umzubringen Zahlen das ist dämlich.
0,375 in Bayern gegen der aus ich mich jetzt hier verrechnet kommen wir auf 100 Millionen.
Von allen deutschen oder was einschließlich in den besetzten Gebieten Blick.
So etwas ist natürlich sehr schön wenn jemand so etwas sagen weil das natürlich zeigt okay offenbar müssen noch mehr Menschen.
Ihren Unmut kundtun damit damit das da ankommt wie ich glaube auch eher dass das so eine so etwas war.
Womit er sich selber trösten wollte so mein Gott oh mein Gott.
Ja es ist Polizeistatistik wurde ja wieder veröffentlicht.
Wie Deutschland ist so sicher wie nie zuvor ja alle so gut wie alle dort statistisch erfassten vergehen sind rückläufig.
Muss man natürlich dazu sagen nicht alles wird dort erfasst wir haben ja auch unterschiedliche Dunkelziffern in verschiedenen Delikt Feldern also es heißt nicht dass alles automatisch zurückgeht.
Aber das große EWE Wohnungseinbrüche und sowas geht alles zurück also wir müssen jetzt eigentlich nicht noch mehr Befugnisse haben aber natürlich genau deshalb brauchen wir noch mehr damit das noch mehr.
Komm jetzt zu unserem Lieblings was.
Danke ich habe ein Handy bekommen.
Ach echt.
0,3% der Wahlberechtigten in Bayern demonstrieren gegen das neue polizeiaufgabengesetz das ist respektabel und deren gutes Recht immerhin.
So also ich meine Haare auch schon andere gehört ne aber es zeigt auch dass die Bayern fast vollständig geschlossen hinter unseren konsequenten.
Sicherheitspolitik und dem neuen TAG Stellen stehen Michael Koffer.
Der soll sich mal löschen.
Kommissar Moser Lieblingsthemen Fake News.
Facebook Facebook und Feldherr.
Facebook doch alles drin was wir geil finden oder ja.
Der ist aber tatsächlich das wenn ich das Handy sehr interessante Meldung also facebook hat sich ja vor ich glaube Ende 20 Anfang 2017 haben die sicher entschieden.
Fake News also Tatsachenbehauptungen die im 2 defect check nicht standhalten.
Als solche zu kennzeichnen da kam also dann so ein kleiner Warnhinweis rotes Ausrufezeichen oder so.
Diese dieser Artikel oder Behauptung in diesem Artikel werden von fact Check an in Zweifel gezogen oder so und.
Das war ich mal zu mal ne das war ja so ein Schritt in die wo sie eben irgendwie der Verbreitung Einhalt gebieten wollten.
Ohne wirklich einzugreifen in die Verbreitung sie haben sich halt nur besonders hervorgehoben diese Artikel und genau das.
Eine roten Warnhinweis haben sie gegeben Warnung stop Alarm.
Genau alle stop Achtung hier ist was interessantes beim durchscrollen deiner timeline.
Das war der Effekt den sie hatten sie haben festgestellt seitdem sie das eingeführt haben sind die sind die Artikel mit diesen Warnhinweis finden mehr Aufmerksamkeit.
Und mehr Verbreitung also die Einträge wurden häufiger geteilt weil natürlich bei den Chemtrail opfern.
Dann der der Effekt Einsätze so schnell verbreiten bevor sie löschen und weil die hat beim Durchgang durch die Timeline eben einen den saliente Rennreiten gegenüber einem anderen deswegen ändert Facebook jetzt.
Installieren drin Reitz.
So sorry.
Auffälliger das auf der das auffallende reizt wenn jetzt also dass das Ausfallen der Wahrnehmung Objekt.
Darf ich dass es eben farblich hervorgehoben war.
Und jetzt ändern sie ihre ihren um ihre Strategie denn sie stellen die jetzt kleiner da also man wenn jetzt auf Facebook so ein Beitrag geteilt wird dann wird er irgendwie.
Artikelbild genommen Unternehmen invidia der über die Überschrift und daneben I Teasertext und Sohn das ändern Sie jetzt hat kleiner da nur noch mit so der Überschrift.
Und man da drunter eine Box related articles wo sie soll die ganzen Artikel präsentieren die dem widersprechen.
Bin ich mal finde ich tatsächlich mal ganz also.
Interessant dass die sowas noch lernen müssen 2018 also das war jetzt quasi vorhersehbar aber andererseits auch.
Also das dass dieser Effekt hat sächlich eingetreten ist in dieser in diesem Ausmaß und das sind nun darum daran arbeiten zusammen und geht dann dann Kern was halt ein bisschen runter.
Und frankieren es mit widersprüchliche widersprechender Informationen ist vielleicht auch eine interessante Idee.
Machen Sie das jetzt ab sofort oder erst ab November.
Ich war eben also das war jetzt gerade von einer Konferenz ende April weil sie ab wann die das Umsetzen also die machen solche Sachen ja im Zweifelsfall mit ABS am am lebenden Objekt und dann halt einen Vortrag.
Bei der Ätzgel Konferenz wo sie darüber reden gesagt haben wir uns das mal angeschaut wie kann man der Verbreitung von Unwahrheiten entgegentreten und das ist eben wir ändern unsere Strategie da jetzt.
Mal schauen wie das klappt finde ich auf jeden Fall ganz interessant aber die sind natürlich auch immer an dieser vorsichtigen.
Sehr gefährlichen Grenze zu eben Einschränkung der Meinungsfreiheit und Eingriffen in in die frei in den freien Ausdruck der Menschen und das ist natürlich etwas was man auch nicht unbedingt will.
Und damit diese auf jeden Fall total creepy sind haben sie sich gesagt hey pass auf dann machen wir noch ein machine learning Algorithmus.
Der soll ich Artikel die Unwahrheiten beinhaltet schneller erkennt also quasi die man teilt und auf Dinge bei Facebook was auch immer 1 dazu getrieben hat und dann kommt er.
Kommt dieser machine learning Algorithmus und zakwasie eine Wahrscheinlichkeit vorher dass es sich dabei um Zeckenbiss handelt oder nicht also im Prinzip guckt er halt für.
Für alles voll bis zum ersten Slash auf der breit versteht oder nicht ne also wäre die einfachste Methode er prüft halte sie mit Textanalyse ob dieser Artikel einen anderen Fake News Artikel bestimmt.
Entspricht und sag ihm dann die Wahrscheinlichkeit an dass es sich um Fake News handelt und mit dieser Priorität geben Sie das dann ihren fact Check an und dann kriegen die fact Checker quasi vor gefilterte Informationen.
Und das ist wieder so eine Idee die echt gut klingt wenn man keine 2 Minuten drüber nachdenkt,
dass du jetzt irgendwie diesen machine learning Wahrheit Algorithmus mach.
Der der irgendwie halt Vorfilter für deine fact Checker alles ist wieder dieses so ja erst in zweiter Ebene kriegt ein Mensch und was sie soll machine learning Algorithmus eigentlich kill,
gelernt hat wissen wir nicht aber der wird schon wird schon nichts Falsches machen und ich glaube dass sie da mal wieder echt mit dem mit dem Feuer spielen.
Ja also ich meine überhaupt dieser ganze glaube dass man mit machine learning das in Griff kriegen kann.
Er besser als hätten sie es jetzt mit einer blockchain in Griff gekriegt.
Na wer weiß also ich hatte viel Gutes drüber gehört das soll ja.
Koalitionsverträge der Öffentlichkeit sogar zum Glänzen bringen.
Zum Glänzen bringen.
Ja das ist auf jeden Fall nach wie vor so merkwürdig ist gerade ein rennen und.
Diese Problematik des machine learning zunächst einmal halt auch nur den aktuellen Stand widerspiegelt und schwer die Zukunft vorhersagen kann denke das wird,
noch lange Zeit zu bleiben dass sich das immer wieder gegenseitig ausgleichen musste mir auch ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig sicher dass das auch noch irgendwann mal gut wird.
Und wenn dann ist vielleicht auch der technische Aufwand auch nur so groß dass sie nur wenige leisten können.
Widerspruch.
Hier gibt es auf jeden Fall ne Menge Leute die dagegen halten können und die sagen ja nix hier.
Dann Kommentare was soll man dazu noch sagen aus dem Kind die sich mit Facebook gar nicht ausführen.
Stimmt.
Dann kommen wir doch zu.
Tja zu Twitter bzw zu unseren Freunden von Cambridge analytica dieser Shady und angeblich aufgelösten insolventen Firma in Bethanien schon erwähnt.
Nee die haben ein Lied es ging die Meldung rum dass sie jetzt in den Geschäftsbetrieb einstellen weil sie zahlungsunfähig gegangen sind.
Ja aber letztlich für mir den wir um weil halt einfach der Name durch ist Ivo irgendwie irgendwo.
India.
Solution irgendwas von anderer Name auf jeden Fall also die Leute gehen so schnell nicht weg solange die nicht im Knast sitzen ist auch,
nicht ganz klar wie Großbritannien damit die so wirklich umgeht in der Öffentlichkeit weil da hat der Vorfall das für eine Menge Aufmerksamkeit gesorgt zu Meyer und das habe ich auch schon mal angesprochen.
Letztlich auch vermutet wird das auch die ganze brexit Kampagne auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise da brennt beschleunigt wurde.
Und da habe ich noch mal sehr gespannt ob das noch mal irgendeine Auswirkung hat.
Dicker überhaupt generell zu retten sind das wird auch sehr davon abhängen ob dieser brexit irgendwie noch wirklich stattfindet oder ob der nicht auf den letzten Metern noch so richtig gegen die Wand fährt.
Du hast ja noch Hoffnung.
Hoffnung würde ich jetzt nicht sagen aber das Problem ist das.
Immer klarer wird dass ich einfach keines der versprechen dass keines der Versprechen gehalten werden kann und das ist halt ein echtes sofort messbares Problem sein wird und zwar auf so einem.
Aber ihre EU-Domain dürfen sie schonmal behalten.
Da komme dann später noch mal zu aber was war denn jetzt mit Twitter Twitter und Cambridge analytica also es kam die Information heraus dass dieser Professor Alexander,
Quran werden uns der halt dieses this is your digital life diese App auf Facebook,
gefahren hat die dann unter anderem dem vielen anderen Quellen den Datenstand von Cambridge analytica halt erweitert hat weil eben jeder der eingewilligt hat Prinzip weil das bei Facebook noch offen war auch mal ebenso die Profile,
alle Freunde dieser Person auch noch gleich mit ausgeliefert hat.
Und nun kam halt raus das Wunder auf Wunder auch Twitter hier eine Datenquelle war das glaube ich jetzt an der Stelle keinen.
Bruder.
Na ja allerdings nicht in diesem Ausmaß ne also der hatte Zugriff auf Daten eines Tages 2015 mit seinem Unternehmen global finance research.
Und der hat ja auch ursprünglich mit diesem wissenschaftlichen Vorwand die Daten von von Facebook gesammelt und dann an Cambridge analytica gegeben.
Und der hatte jetzt laut Twitter einen einmaligen Zugriff über unternehmenseigene Schnittstellen also die Enterprise Search LPIS.
Und hatte er allem hat er eine zufällige Auswahl öffentlicher Tweets aus dem Zeitraum von Dezember 2014 bis April 2015.
Abgegriffen und der hatte das ändert sich an Bedingungen geknüpft gewesen an dir.
Du machst ja jetzt kein Unfug mit oder nein nein nein nein.
Aber der hat heute ja der hat heute einfach mal auch Twitter Daten genutzt jetzt.
Also ist auf jeden Fall auch tragisch und nicht in Ordnung und ärgerlich aber die sind halt ohnehin öffentlich ne.
Dass die Frage ob Zwitter eigentlich noch irgendwelche Daten auch akkumuliert über diese Profile die noch als Metadaten abgelegte darüber habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt keine Kenntnis das natürlich jetzt nicht so wie bei facebook wurde ja irgendwie permanent angibt.
Bin jetzt gerade mein zusammen zu sein aber letztlich wir wissen ja wenn man erstmal tiefer reinschaut.
Kann man das ganze Menge bekommen man früher konnte so den ganzen Twitter Strom bekommen also den ersten Tagen von Twitter da war ja alles zu haben.
Na ja.
Der hat auf jeden Fall also twitter hat Cambridge analytica und alle Unternehmen die mit chemisch Analytiker zu tun haben.
Als Werbekunden gesperrt das hat ja Facebook auch getan und ich denke das ist auch der Grund ist,
erkenne ich Analytiker eben ja mehr oder weniger Insolvenz anmelden musste weil sie eben ganz nachvollziehbar eindeutig in Zukunft kein Geschäft mehr machen konnten also haben sie hat den Laden,
platzen lassen und neuen aufgemacht ist ja ganz klar was willst du sonst machen.
So dazu fällt keinem was ein dann können wir uns ja das jetzt ein.
Muss immer ein bisschen mehr Zeit geben das ist er.
Wieso man kann ja auch schon vorher beschließen dass man was hat oder müssen wir mal auffordern gucken wir testen das gerade haben wir üben wie man so müde und Logbuch und so dann noch auf Anfang.
Man kann also Schilder hochhalten oder fahren.
Shadow Lizard auf jeden Fall herzlich eingeladen.
T-Shirt ausziehen oder so aber sag mal dazu auch noch was was was soll man dazu auch noch sagen.
Danke noch ein schönes Thema Twitter und GitHub haben Passwörter weggelockt das war also wie wieder die haben halt irgendwie also.
Wie konnte das passieren.
Ich habe das gestern über die Sendung aufgenommen weil ich dachte vielleicht muss man das kann man das noch mal erklären also wenn ihr euch bei einem Dienst anmeldet.
Was hat aber erstmal sagen was passiert ist eingeloggt heißt ja jetzt nicht absichtlich die Passwörter Weg geschrieben sondern wie es den Anschein hat war das wieder so auf die Welle Ebene irgendwo gabs Code der.
Die Passwörter einfach so als debug output rausgeschmissen hat das landet in irgendwelchen Dateien und immerhin bevor irgendein scheiß drauf kam.
Hat bitte einfach mal an alle Numerus geschrieben und gesagt so hier immer.
Passwort wir glauben zwar dass das noch bei uns geblieben ist aber und so und du solltest sowieso mal kein Passwort verwenden was woanders.
Da wäre ich gerade gleich gleich zu bekomme ich woll.
Ich wollte auch mal was sagen.
Ich wollte einfach nur dass wir aus dem Konzept gebracht.
Das mache ich ja gerne.
Wenn also die Frage die sich ja vielleicht in den Laien stellt.
Wieso soll natürlich weiß bitte mein Passwort die müssen sie soll ich mich denn sonst anmelden,
und die einspeichern nämlich normalerweise wenn sie es richtig machen eben eine Prüfsumme des Passworts eine sehr lange Prüfsumme von der sehr unwahrscheinlich ist das eine weitere Person ein.
Wo
Oder bzw dass sie das gezielt konstruiert tun kann und so kommt bitte eigentlich darum herum und jeder andere Dienste halbwegs was auf sich hält auch,
die Passwörter wirklich zu speichern also man gibt quasi mein das Passwort ein und eigentlich sollte das quasi nur in den Arbeitsspeicher des Twitter Server einmal kurz die Prüfsumme davon errechnet n&n wird verglichen.
Ob die Prüfsumme die in der Datenbank gespeichert ist die ISS.
Die zudem die gerade errechnet wurde mit dem Passwort was man bis dahin hoffentlich einfach schon wieder aus dem Speicher rausgeworfen hat.
Und offenbar zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt halt angefangen ihr das Infos was sie bekommen an irgendeiner Stelle auch mal wegzulocken und so sind daneben die Klartext Passwörter gelandet.
Wobei das hat die an der Stelle auch insofern schon eine technische Schwachstelle ist als das überhaupt das Passwort im Klartext die andere Seite erreicht.
Man könnte ja dieses ganze Hashing um das zu vergleichen auch schon auf der Webseite.
Nee wär schlecht weil wenn dann die Hashes geklaut werden dann kann sich jeder mit den Hashes anmelden.
Deine Katze genauso gut auch das Passwort klauen in dem Moment wir sind darauf zu.
Nee nee also die Klausur bemächtigt sich der User Datenbank von Twitter.
Dann steht da drin was weiß ich at Tim Pritlove und eben ein langer Herr deines Passwortes wenn dieser Herr hilft dir nicht.
Dich in Zukunft als lauf anzumelden weil du nicht weißt welches Passwort ist ist dass du an Twitter senden muss was am Ende zu diesem Heft führt was dass du dass du dich anmelden könntest würde dein Frontend den Hash berechnen.
Und dann diesen Cache an Twitter senden dann käme das im Prinzip dem Effekt gleich als würdest du einfach direkt das Passwort hinschreiben und Twitter will das Passwort auf die Festplatte.
Ja gut aber wenn man dann noch andere Sizilien vitalhof day damit reinzieht dann geht er so ziemlich dir selber Hash also man könnte auf jeden Fall Wege finden und gibt ja auf Webseiten die das zu tun die.
EasyCut passierte Authentisierung machen.
Aber auch generell einfach erstmal schon mal so eine vor Verschlüsselung vornehmen das halt nicht das Klartext Passwort als solches egal wichtiger ist.
Nein das bin ich doch hier Chinesen so weiter wenn du da dich halt einloggst dann wird eben schon im Kleinen eine Fälschung vorgenommen und das wird erst auf der anderen Seite angegriffen.
Wer hat also halte ich für nicht unbedingt notwendig aber.
Jetzt sehe ich gleich die Kommentare.
Zertifikatsbasierte Anmeldung wäre dazu wäre zu raten aber das machen sie nicht na ja also.
Jetzt aber eigentlich sagen dass die Leute immer Passwort auf die Reihe kriegen sollen.
Genau und Hütter hat es deswegen ist das mit reingenommen Twitter nämlich dann mal also ich finde es ein sehr schönes Beispiel dafür dass.
Es ist eben wirklich nicht empfiehlt überall das gleiche Passwort zu verwenden,
und wieder hat dann dazu auch veröffentlicht wer bitte ändert eure ändert das Passwort bei Twitter und bei jedem anderen Dienst wo ihr vielleicht ist das gleiche Passwort verwendet haben könnte das sollt ihr aber gar nicht machen,
und nutzt ein starkes Passwort und benutze es nicht auf anderen Seiten dann benutzt die Login verification also known as two factor authentication.
Wo man also dann wenn man sich anmeldet eine SMS bekommt und damit quasi die Anmeldung noch einmal bestätigen muss und dann empfehlen wir natürlich zur Nutzung eines Passwort-Manager.
Wo man der Seite die komfortable Möglichkeit dafür ist sehr viele unterschiedliche Passwörter zu haben und wenn dann so etwas passiert.
Eines davon einmal weg gekommen ist ins ins in das richtige Internet entfleucht ist dass man daneben relativ entspannt bleiben kann.
Wer benutzt hier ein Passwort Manager.
Viele Hände gehen hoch.
Wer benutzt kein sorry.
Paar Leute trauen sich das also.
Seid ihr bereit zu erklären war.
Aber du bist das kurz übersetze die audiowelt das war jetzt mit Abstand die deutliche Mehrheit.
Ja also man könnte sagen 0,3% fahren.
Die deutliche Mehrheit steht hinterm Passwort-Manager.
Ja so siehts aus.
Möchte jemand also möchte ich wirklich vielleicht habt ihr gute Gründe wenn nicht dann sag lieber ihr wollt es nicht erklären.
Hier vorne ist ein mutiger Moment ich habe schon über ein anderes Passwort kombiniertes allerdings auch System und damit bleibt das Passwort nur in meinem Kopf für dich bist mein Grund.
Komm du kombinierst das mit was das richtig verstanden.
Ich habe System für mein Passwort aber trotzdem überall verschiedene Passwörter.
Erklär mir das System.
Also ich werde vorsichtig bei diesem System aber.
Kann man versuchen also sollte halt nicht z.b. sowas nein so mein geheimes Passwort Amazon wo hätte ich vielleicht der das passiert danach okay ich glaube ich kenne das mein geheime Passwort ebay aber.
Also ich finde man sollte sich auf jeden Fall der erste Schritt ist starke der erste Schritte starke Passwörter und überall ein anderes und es ist auch sehr schön dass das Zwitter da jetzt noch mal so eine kleine edukative Maßnahmen macht.
Passwort meine Damen und ein paar andere nette Vorteile der die sich verwende hat z.b. auch immer so eine aktualisierte Datenbank darüber auf welchem System den jetzt gerade in Bridge passiert ist.
Das heißt man kriegt immer so schön angezeigt so hier auf der Zeit hast du ein Account da ist 90 was gelegt worden hier noch mal besondere Aufmerksamkeit.
Liebst du hinweisen wir können ja auch mal ein sicheres Passwort geben mit cetera oder mal aktualisieren.
Dieser eine Passwort-Manager hat jetzt glaube ich auch so gerne Integration von Hawaii pinpoint von dem von Treuhand Seite da herbei pinpoint kennst du nicht.
Poverty point was ist das wenn man auf einer Porno Webseite auf.
Nee also jetzt müsste zimmerackerstraße erklären das ist ja auch ein seltener rum.
Ich weiß schon was du meinst keine Angst.
Also es gibt diese der der sammelt im Prinzip in dieser Datenbank Betroffene.
Betroffene E-Mail Adressen von data breaches dann kannst du alter deine E-Mail-Adresse eingeben und dann sagt er dir in welchen öffentlich bekannten liegt diese E-Mail-Adresse im Zweifelsfall vorhanden oder betroffen war.
Das ist immer ganz praktisch wenn man sich jetzt also wenn man mal so eine andere E-Mail-Adresse da ein gibt ausversehen.
Und dann genau weiß in welchem Lied man die Passwörter dazu findet aber das das ist nicht der Indie intendierte Nutzung dieser Seite.
Aber das ist so eine der wenigen wo man der Typ ist auf jeden Fall relativ bekannt und das ist so eine der wenigen Seiten.
Wo man will ich sagen halt ja mal so eine E-Mail-Adresse echt eingeben kann.
Um um sie zu prüfen weil der hat inzwischen was sein Ruf angeht und so auf jeden Fall mehr zu verlieren als eure E-Mail-Adresse wert ist insofern.
Glaube ich das ist das ist schon so ein Dienst Jessen Nutzung man mal empfehlen kann z.b. auch also für mich ist er leider nicht brauchbar weil ich nicht nur die Passwörter ändern bei jedem Dienst sondern auch die E-Mail-Adresse.
Und das macht jetzt ein bisschen schwierig die alle bei Herrieden suitsupply zu prüfen.
Kannst du mal gucken ob ich mit dem indumont mich unterhalten kann aber ja also wenn man ihre Großmutter ist email ab und zu mal kurz checkt oder so Großvaters E-Mail-Adresse auf dem ersten liegt Waren oder so.
Oder der hat einfach mal zu sagen Eltern war dein Passwort bei bei pornhub oder so keine Ahnung also das ist auf jeden Fall ganz guter.
Gut, zu weiteren Überwachungstechnologien.
Wir sind jetzt übrigens Tim inzwischen sag das nur bei den Kurzmeldungen.
Ja na wir sind was ist das jetzt ein Aufruf an Dich oder ein Aufruf an mich.
Es ist immer ein Aufruf an Dich mir möglichst keine spezifischen Nachfragen zu stellen weil ich nicht beantworten kann.
Wolltest nicht weiß achso das ist Kurzmeldung ich habe keine Ahnung heißt das achso das ist gut.
Kurzmeldung heißt wir machen das jetzt kurz.
Na gut dann kann ich das ja erzählen ne also seit 2017 gibt's in Wales.
Artikel ehemaligen Vereinigten Königreich Test also der testet die Polizei ein System zur automatischen Gesichtserkennung und zwar in Echtzeit.
Wetter tolles Wort.
Ja ich habe es irgendwann mal vor Kameras irgendwie auf der CeBIT erklärten alle wann total beeindruckt na weil ich irgendwie die News des Tages Welt der einzige war der nicht gestempelt hat soll sofort mit zwei Sitzen irgendwas gesagt hat.
Was denn was ist Echtzeit ist jetzt oder oder jetzt.
Ich habe doch etwas gesagt wie in einer Echtzeit ist wenn irgendwie so schnell verarbeitet und ausgewertet werden kann dass man halt nicht merkt dass Wortart Vergangenes brauchst du was.
Die Sommernacht sowie gerade ganz gut gepasst aber sie war sehr viel mehr davon beeindruckt dass ich dich gleich gegen die Decke geguckt habe als so was anderes was auf PC mit läuft das irgendwie anders.
Naja auf jeden Fall die Polizei wollte das mal testen und hat sich dafür unter anderem oder nur einen Champions-League-Finale ausgesucht das war echt in Wales.
Nierensteine was kostet was.
Das müsstest du wissen nicht ich.
Ja das stimmt naja auf jeden Fall haben sie da mal endlich draufgehalten und wollte mal gucken wenn sie da irgendwie so erkannt bekommen.
Und da waren wohl so potenziell 170 000 Besucher in der Stadt sowas nicht mehr jetzt auf dieser Veranstaltung so drumherum sie habe ich nicht im Stadion gemacht sein der Stadt und guckt.
Warst du denn da so erkannt bekommen und haben wohl 2470 mögliche Treffer angezeigt also Gesichter von den sie meinten dass sie vielleicht kennen.
Weiß ich allerdings nicht genau wie groß ihre Datenbasis war also von wie vielen.
Aber es stellte sich dann halt bei der Überprüfung heraus dass ein Großteil.
Mit 2297 ein Mann ein false positiv fahren.
Interessant weil die also die müssten natürlich eigentlich zwei Sachen also diskutierte falls negativ können Sie jetzt nicht messen weil sie verbergen sicher in den 170.000 anderen,
aber natürlich 92% False Positives ist auf jeden Fall der ist noch Optimierungspotenzial vielleicht sollte man da mal mit was mit blockchain oder so machen den sollte man echt zu blockchain raten da sind die erstmal drei Jahre beschäftigt.
Ist es ungesund Projekte aufzuhalten und sowas ohne blockchain und so ist kommt er doch überhaupt nicht vorwärts.
Zeig mir das was für den Flughafen.
Aber immer noch 173 über diese Seite die erkannt haben und dann wartet.
Ich weiß nicht was sie da gemacht habe wahrscheinlich wann das ihre Testperson oder sowas aber der Hersteller NEC von dem.
Hat das natürlich damals als einen großen Erfolg gefeiert diese Seite sind wie kaputt von denen großer Erfolg der Nebel nach einer sekunde nur noch 20 18 vielleicht haben wir ein Adblocker Blocker in ihrer Pressemitteilung oder so.
Tja was sagt denn das jetzt eigentlich das heißt es ist überhaupt erstmal möglich.
Naja überhaupt erstmal möglich ist ein großes Wort wenn du 92% falsch machst.
Na gut aber ich meine wenn das dann 173 meist gesuchte Terroristen sind oder die gewaltbereiten Fußballfans wir so schön heißt dann wird sowas schnell auch mal als Erfolg gefeiert.
Das ist wahrscheinlich Erde haben sie ja eben auch getan ne wie seht ihr das.
Was ist die Frage.
Das deins.
Wie ist die Frage vom.
Instrument.
Ja aber dieser Treffer die die ausgewertet haben das haben wir doch wahrscheinlich von Hand im Nachhinein gemacht weil diese.
Weiß nicht 2000 Leute die kann man ja nicht live dann noch mal verifizieren dass das tatsächlich falsche Treffer sind bzw halt ganz paar richtige.
Das heißt die kann man auch nicht fangen und 2000 Leute einfach mal so.
Weg zu Kashan ist glaube ich auch ein logistischer Aufwand für so ein Fußballspiel.
Das ist richtig als erstes das Echtzeit Gebot wurden bei den 173 nicht gewahrt.
Die wussten ja nicht welche 173 richtig sind von ihren 2470.
Das stimmt das heißt wenn sie wirklich in dem Moment Zugriff hätten haben wollen hätten sie nur bestenfalls zugestellt danach festgestellte oder da war ja alles voll mit Terroristen.
Aber leider krank.
Ja sofern ist es in der Tat ein. Dass dass das nicht so weit tragen könnte heute Hinweis.
Ja ich würde jetzt einfach mal davon ausgehen dass es wahrscheinlich die Polizei von Wild auch nicht unbedingt die besten Leute hat um sowas zementieren und dass man da vielleicht in anderen Ländern z.b. China vermutlich schon deutlich bessere System am laufen hat.
Das ist natürlich genau also NEC ist in Tokio Tische Hersteller wenn ich das nicht richtig sie also das ist das noch Schwaben nee nee das ist schon das schon Japan.
Ja Baden ist das.
Essen japanischer Hersteller.
Ich kann mir es ist sicherlich so dass es dass es bessere Systeme gibt und vor allem bist halt die Frage feiert man jetzt.
Dass die Systeme schlecht sind und konzentriert sich quasi im Protest so sehr drauf wenn.
So oder so auf wenn es jetzt noch nicht soweit ist man sehr zeitnah davon ausgehen kann dass es eben besser funktioniert ne die haben übrigens auch als einer der Hauptgründe.
Ganz schön warum das nicht geklappt hat ja also schuld war nicht Ihr System.
Sondern schlechte Bilder die sie von der UEFA und von Interpol bekommen haben also die haben sich quasi über einen nicht über ihr seid zwar nicht ihr systemschutz sondern die schlechte Vergleichsbasis die in Polizei und Interpol Polizei und.
UEFA gegeben haben für die im Lichte eingefahren für diesen Massen Einsatz.
Das war übrigens Kurzmeldung.
Das war ein Kurzmeldung Tipp,
wirkliche Kurzmeldung ist wer das finde ich habe ich bisher nur ganz am Rande gefunden das ist so eine richtig passt denke so kann das über sein weil ich da so wenig zu finde.
Es gibt seit 10 Jahren einen Rechtsstreit zwischen dem Musikproduzenten Pedersen und YouTube und der Oder Peter Sonnen wie auch immer ein Musikproduzent der irgendwie ein.
Lied geschrieben hat.
Dass er von einer dass dass das album Winter Symphony der britischen Sängerin Sarah Brightman hatte.
Und hat daran die ausschließlichen Rechte innen und er möchte nicht dass er möchte gerne das YouTube.
Privat Konzertmitschnitte davon Schwert als ist ja schon eine relativ auf relativ ordentlicher Aufgabe ja also.
Das.
So ein privat Mitschnitt hat ja regelmäßig auch nicht so gute Tonqualität dass mir wieder alte sind muss alles gesperrt werden und Bilder und wo die Musik drin ist und die Frage ist ist YouTube.
Dazu verpflichtet das zu tun na ja wenn er sich beschwert auf jeden Fall so viel haben ja glaube ich schon geklärt die Frage ist.
Ist YouTube dazu verpflichtet das auch vorher zu tun.
Und das ist natürlich juristisch in diesem Bereich der Haftung also würde YouTube haften für illegal hochgeladene Inhalte also wieder so ein Streit den wir auch inzwischen seit so vielen.
So vielen Jahren haben ja also Plattform Haftung für für Uploads in Zweifel natürlich am Ende die Frage ablauffilter.
Und das wie soll der Bundesgerichtshof jetzt relativ bald entscheiden und es gab offenbar in diesem Verfahren.
Vorgestern den Aufschlag die Entscheidung habe ich jetzt noch nicht gesehen also der der Bundesgerichtshof hat das als Revision zugelassen.
Und wir darüber wird wohl darüber eine Grundsatzentscheidung fällen wollen ich hoffe mal die richtige.
Giftig die Vorentscheidung war ja vom Oberlandesgericht Hamburg und die meinten halten müssen sie nicht.
Was interessant ist wenn selbst Hamburg das entscheidet.
Ja das stimmt ja ich finde ja das hat mir noch schon oft ne das diese.
Everest Debatte die begleitet unter den ganzen Tag Schwindelgefühl Zeit immer und will nicht weggehen aber ich finde,
die fordern so viel sollte irgendwie auch mal ein bisschen zurückfordern und find auch so dieses registrieren von urheberrechtlichen Material wird langsam auch mal Zeit wo sowieso viel Kontinent gibt also ich habe ja nichts dagegen dass du einen,
Rechtsanspruch.
Ja dass er besteht und durchgesetzt werden kann ist ja aber man sieht immer nur viel Forderung aber relativ wenig Pflichten für die Urheber und einfach malen Verzeichnis.
Eine ordnungsgemäße Registrierung nach dem Motto was nicht registriert ist ist auch nicht geschützt wer langsam auch mal an der Zeit.
Münstersche also meistens lässt sich umsetzen also ist das nicht ist Content ID nicht das.
Containerdienst einfach eine private Initiative quasi von von Google und ja arbeiten sie halt zusammen und sie haben dann quasi eine Datenbank aber ich rede halt von einer richtigen.
Registrierung und nicht bei Google sondern eben an einer zentralen Datenbank so nach dem Motto hier ist ein Werk für dieses Werk für dich mein Urheberrecht auch wirklich.
Anerkannt wissen und durchgesetzt wissen und dann gibt's da auch eine ID dazu und dann gibt es auch mal klare Aussagen darüber dann kann man halt auch mal recherchieren,
ist etwas überhaupt urheberrechtlich geschützt so und man kann halt dahingehend dass auch überprüfen.
Darf jemand anders die man arbeiten kann.
Da ist doch direkt.
Das ist ja genau das was Kodak jetzt mit ihrer blockchain erreichen will dass man.
Jetzt hast du auch das Podcast gibt's hier jetzt auch mit blockchain.
Da hinten.
Ja Logbuch Netzpolitik l sportlich Moment meines Wissens ist es so dass bei der GEMA sowieso schon eine Registrierung notwendig ist die GEMA okay.
Der ist dieses Lied ne dieses bestimmt verliebt.
Bei der GEMA ist eine Registrierung erforderlich damit die GEMA die Rechte dafür wahrnimmt.
Also ich mache jetzt explizit von Urheberrecht ne was ja immer automatisch sofort und ohne Ansage sozusagen greift ne.
Also das Café was nicht nur nach vorheriger Register sonst gibt es nicht.
Man muss auch explizit abgibt wenn man das so sagen nicht nur mit einer gewissen Karenzzeit jetzt da gibt's sicherlich viele Details über die man sich unterhalten muss aber es wäre auf jeden Fall auch noch mal interessanter NASA ich habe da auch mal ein Podcast zugemacht zu dem Thema.
Okay dann dann können wir den nehmen.
Genau.
Unsere Freunde der digital courage werden gerade abgemahnt weil sie weil es da diesen schutzranzen gab ne auch wieder so eine geniale Idee also.
Nämlich also Kinder die genau kinderüberwachung im.
Kinderüberwachung.
Sony die Idee war dass diese Ranzen dann ein GPS Tracker haben der die ganze Zeit einfach immer sagt wo das Kind ist die Eltern darauf Zugriff haben damit zu wissen wo der Tornister von dem Kind ist ne also ist und.
Außerdem Killer Feature das Kind wird nicht mehr überfahren weil sie mit den Autoherstellern zusammen sprechen zusammenarbeiten wollten die nämlich dann quasi das wenn die wenn da ewig Kinder in der Nähe der Straße sind.
Das dann die dass das Auto dann irgendwie Halltal anzeigt Achtung Kinder ne.
Auf so vielen Ebenen eine dumme Idee also erstens.
Lass mal diese ganzen helikopter-eltern tun aber der erste der sich so ein Ding kaufen würde wäre auf jeden Fall ich und ich würd es immer beim Fahrradfahren dabei haben.
Damit ich nicht vom LKW überfahren werde wie auch gerade in München wieder geschehen und so sind einfache Dinge die wir nicht replizieren ich würde kaufen nicht mit euch die schenken und versteckt die irgendwo dauerhaft ne.
Anna.
Genau was steckt immer auf der A3.
Dann war das Ding dann war es noch komplett komplett kaputt da sind ja dann paar Leute vom Club mal haben das mal kurz angeschaut.
Lass mich raten irgendwas mit Bluetooth.
Medi solche Sachen sind natürlich direkt noch an der III kaputt ne also du konntest irgendwie konnte seit jedes Kind ihr woanders hintun das heißt du hättest ja noch.
Noch nicht mal die Mühe machen müssen also erstens konntest du alle alle GPS Daten auslesen und werde es dir noch nicht mal die Mühe machen müssen.
Irgendwas auf der Autobahn zu Fall zu verstecken so du jetzt halt einfach aus.
Find im Internet irgendwie immer sagen können friert es gibt da komplett kaputt was auch noch.
Das hör mal die geile Ausrede sich ein Fass werfen Sie mir vor dass Ihr Kind angefahren habe wenn Ihr Kind nicht in der Lage ist ich komme korrekt in mein System einzublenden.
Also ich meine die Liebe.
Was soll das für ein Feature sein wenn du wenn du mit dem Auto irgendwie zu Schulzeiten darum fährst und dein Auto Sattel vorsicht diese Kinder mit ihr sagt der Vater war der Universität datenschutzfreundlich der sagt nicht wo das Kind ist.
Ist nur hier irgendwo muss ein sein und ich weiß nicht wo die das mit Kinder.
Zu verknüpfen wäre auf jeden Fall ganz fürchterlich Idee also dann noch dieses helikopter-eltern tun.
Ich glaube das ist wirklich eine völlig beknackt Idee und der campaigner Friedemann hat die Koko driver GmbH in einem Vortrag als Schrott ab bezeichnet.
Und das wollen sie nicht sie sind ein erfolgreiches Startup und da deswegen hat sie jetzt abgemahnt und irgendwie noch paar andere Sachen ja digital courage damit jetzt auf jeden Fall irgendwie Geld um sich dagegen zu wehren dann seid ihr wie eine Anwalt eine Nacht dran gesessen also so viel Geld werde wahrscheinlich auch nicht brauchen.
Aber man kann sich vorstellen dass wenn sich wenn sich da einmal drauf eingeschossen haben heute auf.
Wenn man wenn man von helikopter-eltern Rucksäcke baut dann muss man sich eben auch verarschen lassen.
Sag mal wollt ihr noch ein bisschen Meinung auf dem Publikum.
Ja immer.
Man könnte doch kreativ für virtuelle Depots missbrauchen.
Dürfen Kinder demonstrieren.
Nein ich meine wenn die Abi kaputt ist kann man doch sagen oder sind ganz viele Kinder auf der A3 auf einmal.
Und dann könnte man sagen die Lügenpresse die Lügenpresse sagt da waren nur da war nur 30000 Leute dabei waren allein schon 100000 Kinder.
Wer denk mal an die Kinder hier.
Unsinn Unsinn.
Oder würdest du deine Kinder mit so einem schutzranzen.
Nicht ohne Schutzfolie also warum warum dieses data weißt du woran die sterben werden.
Die werden nicht daran abschmieren dass das wird nicht genug helikopter-eltern in Prenzlauer Berg gibt sie das kaufen nein nein nein die finanzielle ganzen Laden erstmal für ein paar Jahre durch die werden daran sterben,
dass die.
Für den Ranzen wirft das Kind bei der ersten Gelegenheit in die Ecke Weil der schwer ist Smartphone hingegen.
Davon wird das Kind nicht so schnell nicht drin insofern werden die werden diese Tracking Apps für Kinder halt als Apps auf den Smartphones sein.
Tut mir leid ihr Startup kriegt von mir ein Risikokapital.
Japan die Apps gibt auch schon was ist irgendwie alles nichts Neues also jetzt nicht um dann nicht von Autos überfahren zu werden und 2. phantafriends.
Also nicht für die Kinder.
Bitte dich deine Freunde.
Für mich.
Letzte Meldung EU Domains auch für Briten und restliche Welt also ursprünglich durften nur Länder die Mitglieder der Europäischen Union sind.
Auch die EU Top-Level-Domains beantragen oder Leute die in diesen Ländern wohnen.
Und die Kommission hat diesen Passus nun abgeschafft damit kann jede Interessentin eine EU-Domain beantragen ob sie nun aus einem EU Land stammt oder nicht ist dabei völlig egal.
Leider sind wir jetzt wahrscheinlich eingeknickt einfach.
Der wichtigste Hebel gewesen Tim ne damit hätten wir den brexit noch verhindern.
Ja weiß nicht.
Und damit wären wir es jetzt genau jetzt was auf die jetzt kommt die Termin Sektion.
Rund.
Wir haben also ich kann's nicht vorher sagen welche Termine wir haben hatten von euch noch jemand einen Termin der mit in die Termin Sektion soll.
Und fühlt sich bereit den hier live im Takt Melodie zur Preis.
Bitte das mal gucken ob ich überhaupt nicht allein die Musik richtig runter zu regeln ja bin ich.
Also wenn es keiner freiwillig macht dann sehen wir jemanden aus ne.
Was sind die sollen jetzt unsere Termine vorlesen.
Nenne die unsere Termin ist gibt es ich habe draußen noch ein Plakat gesehen von einem Termin den ich hier noch nicht drauf habe und ich will gucken ob wir nehmen.
Katze selber machen.
Ja muss ich alles machen ich dachte das wäre viel ich dachte es hätte sich jemand.
Überforderst das Publikum für die ist das auch neu na ja eben.
Ja für mich auch okay ich weiß wann der Termin ist so am 2. Juni.
Wird das jetzt alles rausschneiden.
Kommst, würde sich nicht trauen das kann man ruhig ja eben man deswegen frage ich doch okay wenn man jetzt Termine.
Superskull Termine da drin warst du da so was ist das auch Wer ist als Krimi sowie Katalog von Terminen und so weiter und was nicht alles sehr we do it live.
Jingle
Huhu ich muss ja noch runter regeln so was haben denn hier 28 bis 30 September.
Sex on the Beach.
Und zwar geht das nach Norden packt euren friesenherz 1 das geht nach Norddeutschland der Chaos Treff Flensburg lädt euch ein zu den Hacks on the Beach wir richten.
Uns richten uns unser HAK Center im strandpavillon ein wow also auch mit Badeteich und so direkt auf dem Flensburger Strandbad Solitüde Solitüde ist man da irgendwie einsam oder was.
Notiere alles noch ne.
Messer hacken mit Rundumblick über die Flensburger Förde und noch bis nach Dänemark vielleicht wenn man sich anstrengen sogar Russland sehen von da.
Oder Baden-Baden am 2. Juni 2008 um 12 Uhr beginnt das,
Goa das große offizielle Angrillen ausgerichtet von Nordeingang und chaosdorf das gesamte Seibert mit wird an die Rheinwiesen geschleppt,
und es wird ein gemütlicher Tag voller interessanter Ideen lustiger Basteleien und guten,
Essen stattfinden wo das findet ihr auf der Webseite nämlich auf den Neusser Rheinwiesen neben der alten Eisenbahnbrücke.
Ja dann bleibt natürlich nur noch darauf hinzuweisen dass auch Logbuch Netzpolitik demnächst noch mal auf die Bühne gehen zu wie sind heute getan hat aber natürlich in einem epischen Ausmaß deutlich Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 256.
Es gibt noch Tickets aber nur ein paar nicht mehr viel und dann war's das mit den Tickets also sofern bis dann mal ein bisschen durch beschleunigen was das betrifft.
Such das mal samt auszublenden gibt es wird nicht gelingen doch ein bisschen so das bringt uns an das Ende der Sendung.
Am Ende der Sendung kommt immer der Tank,
der Dank gilt auf jeden Fall allen die sich hier so rege beteiligt haben ich wollte eigentlich auch noch Preise ausgeben für Beteiligung könnte aber vielleicht nachher einfach kurz zu mir kommen und dann geht der Dank noch besonders Björn.
Thomas Arnold und Jan und allen anderen die heute hier waren vielen Dank wir uns sehr gefreut.